about 500 episodes in pawn star still
attracts a dedicated audience of history
buffs and Hagler's while the show
presents itself like a documentary
series about a genuine high-end pawn
shop there's a lot that goes on behind
the scenes that the cameras just ignore
so what's the truth about what really
happens at the Gold & Silver Pawn Shop
bad for business when the crew shoots an
episode of Pawn Stars parts of the world
famous Gold & Silver Pawn Shop
temporarily closed to the public which
can sometimes mean a real interruption
of business
according to shop manager Travis Benton
sales to real customers suffer because
of the show since filming takes place
every weekday 2 to 5 times per day
Benton also estimated that one out of a
hundred people who pass through the shop
are actually there to do business the
rest are just there as fans of the show
Rick Harrison back that up big time in
an interview with Las Vegas now claiming
his shop competes would be welcome to
Las Vegas sign for the number one
non-gaming tourist attraction in Las
Vegas and it seems to be true lions
routinely extend down the sidewalk and
sources report that they can sometimes
take up to 3 hours to get through but
visitors should also be aware that if
they're waiting hours to catch a glimpse
of their favorite pond star their
chances aren't great traveler reports
occasionally one of the superstars will
come out from the back where they
produce the show every working day and
sign autographs for about an hour but
before you start thinking that the shop
is in danger of going out of business
because most of their customers are just
there to gawk keep in mind the store
draws 4,000 to 5,000 visitors a day not
to mention Harrison told Las Vegas now
I'm at a point in my life where if I
don't like it I don't have to do it and
Pawn Stars isn't super famous in just
America either an international hits
having been translated into 38 languages
and aired in 150 countries Pawn Stars is
a bona fide international hit 7mo
preserve a Madonna
Austan yet in fact Harrison claims he's
currently suffering the pains of
superstardom
I've been mobbed by people in Buenos
Aires the Philippines Kuala Lumpur New
Delhi everywhere in the world people
know the show the guys even did an Asian
tour in 2013 during which Las Vegas now
said they were quotes greeted as if they
were the reunited Beatles and according
to okj Discovery's fans lined up for
hours at various meet-and-greet events
attended by Harrison and his son Cory
big Hoss Harrison all just for the
chance to lay eyes upon the reality
stars it's pretty remarkable to think
that a TV show about old junk could turn
a couple of guys from a pawn shop into
mega stars on par with rock and roll
legends the Pawn Stars pitch Rick
Harrison says he always knew TV exposure
was good for business
that's why he starred in a 2001 PBS
documentary and agreed to be on Comedy
Central's insomniac in 2003 before
coming up with the idea to pitch an
entire show based on the daily goings-on
of his shop the original concept for
Pawn Stars started on HBO but after a
disastrous pilot and the expiration of
his contract
Harrison turned to left-field
productions the company that still
produces the show today Harrison told
the Star Telegram I figured that a show
would mean free publicity and free
publicity would mean more business but
everyone told me that no one wants to
watch a show about for fat guys in a
pawn shop millions of dollars in profits
later whoever turned Harrison down
couldn't have been more wrong a wild
Chumlee appears
despite his legal troubles Chumlee is
far and away the fan favorite of Pawn
Stars even Harrison knows this as he
once told the Star Telegram that
tourists often opt for the Chumlee
merchandise from one fan some truly a
ton but Chumlee wasn't always part of
the plan
he told Las Vegas now that the show was
originally just a family gig until they
started looking for a fourth cast member
saying they were looking for a fourth
person to put in the show and I thought
to myself well I've known these guys my
whole life we have good camaraderie and
I'm going to be funny and joke with them
like we would normally do and not get
nervous in front of the cameras and it
kind of worked out and by kind of worked
he means he became a multi-millionaire
to endorse sued by their agents the pond
business is a dirty game but the
entertainment industry is worse
especially in the cutthroat world of
celebrity representation in 2012 all 3
Harrison's as well as Chumlee were sued
by the ex manager Wayne Jeffries who
claimed that the Pawn Stars crew dropped
him after a dust-up concerning his
handling of their response to Andy's
spin-off show Cajun pawn stars History
Channel was also sued by a talent agency
called venture IAB whose lawsuit alleged
that network execs worked together with
another agent to lure the guys away from
them Jeffries sought unspecified damages
but venture IAB sued for more than 5
million Harrison didn't seem to be fazed
by either lawsuit telling Fox News the
more money you make the more times
people sue you people are always going
to eventually go to sue you for
something and when it comes to defending
himself in court we're sure he's got a
guy for that thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel let's check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]